hello good humans kendra from jubilee
here thank you so much for checking out
this episode but before we get into this
video we want to thank google for
sponsoring this section of the video
i don't know about you guys but i am
online literally all the time and
dealing with all these new accounts and
passwords can be a bit frustrating so
having one less thing to worry about is
definitely a bonus thank you so much
google's password manager helps keep
your personal information safe online
with their secure password tools that
protect your privacy
i'm constantly talking to people and so
there's a lot of information going
through my head
and the last thing i want to do is
forget a password which is why it helps
to have google's password manager
remember them for you
that way i can focus on things like
casting people for our videos
thanks for watching by the way you can
use google's password manager when
creating a new password for any online
profile or account
and use the recommended secure password
suggestion that password is then saved
to your google account so the next time
you log in
google remembers your password by auto
filling it in for you and if there's
ever a time that you want to review all
your passwords you can just go to your
google account settings or you can visit
passwords.google.com
to take it a step further and make sure
you're using strong passwords you can
use google security checkup where you'll
get personalized recommendations
which is great because if any of your
passwords are ever compromised we'll
prompt you to change them right away
i literally have so many new online
accounts to keep track of just what i've
created in the past year
and it just makes me feel so much better
knowing that google can create all these
passwords
store them remember them everything that
i basically can't do on my own
you can learn more about how google
helps keep you safe online by visiting
passwords.google.com
and thank you again google for
sponsoring this section of the video
hey t t h k d
oh my god i messed up can i do that
again i'm sorry
we brought together seven cheerleaders i
am a cheerleader
i am a cheerleader i am a cheerleader i
am a cheerleader i
am a cheerleader i am a cheerleader i am
a cheerleader
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
okay so names wha what gym we were and
if we were base back spot or flyer yeah
my name's meredith i cheered for
california all-stars for five years and
i was at base
i thought that meredith wasn't a
cheerleader because of her long nails
just because you're always fisting that
tends to hurt your skin okay my name is
anaya
i cheered for about nine years high
school and competitive and i recently
modeled for varsity the spirit
my name is hung i'm in uh uh cal state
fullerton cheer i'm
currently there and i've been cheering
for three years and i'm a back squat
main or psy
hi i'm diana i did the high school cheer
and collegiate cheer and that was the
basement flyer
hi i'm alexi i did high school cheer i
did one year in college because i had to
move back i went
back east you know california state
university credits don't count and so i
did mostly um tumbling
or tumbling as a coach under the
pressure i was like oh my gosh i
have to like get in there and say
something but when it came time to me
saying stuff i'm like oh no i'm losing
words
i'm savannah i've done youth cheer like
my whole life and then i did one year of
all-stars at socal select
and then i do high school cheer now i'm
a flyer by the way my name is ellie um i
did a high school chair and all-star
cheer
okay quickly your favorite thing about
cheer the family aspect of it
eating um i like looking cute and
working hard i like stunting i know
sportsmanship i like looking cute as
well
[Music]
we have a tie the tie is between
alexi and diana each of you is going to
get
20 seconds to prove to the others that
you are a cheerleader
because do you guys want me to do
something yeah go for it yes because
i'll do my my true dance it's been a
while since
is she a cheerleader or a dancer because
when she did that dance it was not as
sharp as cheerleader
great so i did mostly tumbling cheer at
the all-star
athletics cheering gym i was teaching
the mini and the tiny so i'll just show
you what i was gonna do okay
okay
alexi pulled out the back tuck and i got
a little thrown off because i originally
had voted for alexi
sorry it was a little bit unfortunate
everyone was wearing their cheer shoes
or their cheer warm ups and i just came
basically like very normal this will be
the cheer round oh really
can we stretch in the main yeah
oh my god that's now can i do that again
[Music]
a t-t-a-c-k defense
attack let's go
hung did really good his toe touch was
really nice i loved his motions
i heard like the girl was like gasping
because like my toe touch was super high
to the g to the oh yeah go go
all right let's hear it let's go pride
okay i'm dancing because i'm a little
like a cheer dance because i'm a little
too broken to do anything else but
[Music]
okay
mine's a little more simple i'm just
gonna do a field stretch
wait can i do that again hang on okay
she just did the bow and arrow it was
very quick and i think everyone else is
really trying to show their cheer skills
and did a chan or did their fight song
[Music]
oh here we go go go that's right
unite here y'all fight fight w
i am here you all win win together
again let's hear it go fight win let's
go west view
[Music]
the cheer she did was kind of more like
dancy than like sharp
[Music]
you know i i was like what i did was
sucked
so i was like that's fine if you want to
continue playing
please raise your hand in three two
one okay
that is majority getting us all competed
yeah okay so like what competitions have
you been at i've been sharp uh
jams and like nts yeah like ncaa usa
american grand american i love how you
see a thing yeah what's your favorite
polish cheer team or like uh all-star
cheer team kylie code for sure hundred
percent dude
[Applause]
worst like injury you ever had like i
went to physical therapy for years my
ankle so like i had a severe concussion
and i'm like like a couple years ago i
had to quit because of it like
and like i passed out on the ncaa stage
i grew up in a basket and i was behind
her
the heels of her infinity shoes dug into
my head i fell are you okay
why was the nose her nail was so on like
scratch my nose i was
like oh cheer everyone always had a
broken nose everyone's nose is always
crooked
you're too flyer right can't see like
you're like air vest um
no you're good okay wait do that again
why are you not pulling your toe she's a
jordan
she's not going to crease the jordan i
did feel like everybody was kind of like
more like shifted towards this way and i
was kind of like the outlier so i was
like oh i'm trying to inject myself into
the conversation
without like seeming to like suss or
anything actually my parent doesn't know
i'm in cheer
really really yeah that's why i didn't
have my cheering form because i put it
as a waste so like i hit it away and
like
my dad threw it i was like where's that
bag and like you said i throw it away i
thought you don't use it i'm like oh my
god there you go
one thousand dollar money uniforms are
so expensive there's like all-stars yeah
you guys know like what bows of london
are yes yeah we like added up like how
much it would be for like the whole team
and it was like thousands of dollars
just for bows that we wear like
two dates it's the most expensive i feel
like
people don't think cheers they sport
because they think like we're just doing
like in the sidelines
i mean i get like controversial but i
feel like high school cheer isn't as
much because you're not competing for
anything yeah depends
depending on life oh wait there's like
cis so like
i competed in high school and um like
arizona cheer for high school
um when they compete they're really good
i really don't think it's anybody here
so
i don't think it's incredible
that's why i was like yeah yeah i'm like
not a shark coaches
guys don't vote for me it's not me
[Music]
we went to another round so i just kind
of went with the person i
thought was the least convincing
oh sorry
if you want to continue playing please
raise your hand in three
two one
wash your finger across your face
[Laughter]
maybe they're gonna think that like i'm
just like kind of throwing on some
sweats and kind of showed up
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted out the mall and you win
if the light turns red that means the
mole is still in the box
and you lose
[Applause]
[Laughter]
please step forward and reveal yourself
in three
two one
i thought it was turned off no she threw
me off with the toe touch
tug yeah but it was kind of like dancy
that's why dancing
like i did gymnastics
[Music]
for me cheers very much about like
teamwork and sportsmanship and like
working together
it definitely has taught me to be a very
selfless person it's a way of radiating
your energy onto others
in the cheerleading world seeing a guy
in there is kind of like oh
are you actually a cheerleader so you
have to like prove myself more that's
why i have to do all this stuff like
make me fit in
get done
[Music]
you